somebody like caruana does he have a
coach
yes he does he has several coaches these
are people
apart from this team of seconds who
actually give him exercises and
teach him and people don't understand
that because how can
carawanna's coach be 2600 right isn't he
200 points below caruana
yes he is but at that level and at my
level your coach doesn't actually have
to be stronger than you
if you're a 2500 gm you can understand
the game at a very very deep level
and you could still be a specialist in
determining what fabi's mistakes are and
what his weaknesses are
and and using computers you could
enhance that knowledge
it's not all about how good you are you
have to be a baseline level of good
but after that it's all about
understanding of the game i hope that
makes
a little bit of sense and clarifies
[Music]
things
playing at 1200 and uh let's play
another sicilian which we have been
experimenting with now yesterday
uh yep uh west26 i see your question i
will be sure
i've written it down and i will be sure
to address it after the three games okay
what did i tell you guys again uh bishop
c4 is very popular at this level
but the logic behind it is is that you
play e6 and you
blunt the bishop entirely it's just
staring at granite and
in addition to that you can play d5 with
tempo so
all of this is is really good now he
plays the open sicilian so he has an
element of correctness to his play but
again look at this bishop it's just
doing nothing it's it's an empty
developing move
and on top of that sometimes the bishop
belongs on d3 he's giving us a beautiful
pawn center
and he actually is making a very typical
mistake this move
if you're playing the sicilian you have
to sear this into your memory how do we
refute the movie five
those of you who've done some puzzle
rush this morning should be able to spot
this quite quickly
yeah quinn a5 forks upon so whenever
your opponent puts a pawn on an
undefended square like this particularly
when he hasn't castled okay and he's
adding insult to injury
because now we're attacking his king and
we can also take on b2
this is turning into a disaster for
white but one very important thing to
point out
when you're grabbing pawns like this you
want to make
extra certain that you're not abandoning
your developments okay
that's exactly how these short games are
played is you start grabbing the pawns
you fall in love with your position
and you completely forget to continue
and complete your development so let's
actually do that
and that's not a glamorous process
completing your development is often
a process that appears to be rather lame
but but it's not thank you bandidad for
the thousand bits
how should we do that and this is a very
important position actually
so bishop b4 is good bishop b4 develops
with tempo and if he goes rook b1 we can
slide the queen back to a3
uh we do have to be careful about some
tactics here where he takes on b4 and
gives us a discovery against the queen
but since he doesn't really have any
pieces active uh we don't have to worry
about this we'll we'll be able to deal
with it but i'll show after the game
some of the things that you have to be
careful about
when you uh enter into a situation like
this
if this makes sense uh thanks again
banda dad
another thousand bit bomb he goes rook
b3 we're going to drop the queen back
and another thing that we need to be
careful about you see that the bishop is
x-raying the queen this is the type of
situation
which you need to be super cautious
about because it could result like i
just said
in a discovery discoveries are among the
most scary
and the most feared tactics on the
chessboard and for very good reason
uh and one way that he could effectuate
a discovery is by playing a3
distracting our bishop and then removing
the night somewhere
the reason that this isn't as effective
is because
our position is super solid we don't
have any targets in our position
uh and and his pieces are too passive to
support some sort of crazy discovery but
this is an important position
reishidan with 16 oh my lance
an amazing mod and now gifting 16 more
subs stokes the fire and i think we've
reached 1900
we're at the 20th century where should
we go with the bishop
should we take another pawn why or why
not and if not where should we go
very important moments
well when i ask the question like this
most of you probably know that you
should not take the pun
because i asked we should drop it to e7
believe it or not if we take the pawn we
actually lose a piece and here we go he
discovers our queen
but this is nothing to fear thank you
american uh one eleven for the prime now
you ruined
the the round number and we're gonna
drop the queen back to
well actually let's see so he's
attacking our queen we need to move it
um where should we move it where it's
not entirely backward
but it's on a nice square where it's
protected by a pawn shell let's get to
c7 because we're also guarding the d4
the d6 square he can't get like a bishop
to e6 i realize that this is uh
the type of position we haven't really
talked about yet very much and i'm going
quickly through some of these details
this is a very important moment if we
move the rook
he slams his bishop to d6 and he cuts
the lifeline between our queen sign and
our king side we want to be very careful
about that situation
so how should we prevent the bishop from
getting to d6 while not giving up a rook
bingo that's also why we put our queen
on c7 i was going to mention this
but instead we uh made it happen
uh thank you again everybody wishing me
happy birthday let's trade the bishops
although we could have played c4
and uh let's just grab some of the
center no rocket science here we're up
two pawns he's got no compensation
uh and now all we need to do is complete
our developments and continue expanding
in the center and we'll be in very very
good shape
how are we going to do that specifically
well that depends on how he plays
kind of a cute move here would be queen
d4 from his side trying to get his rook
to the seventh rank in trading queens in
that case
okay he's on rook b3 play has gotten
much tighter but i'm trying to
illustrate that the principles i abide
by are not
fundamentally different from those i
started with where should we plant this
bishop and with what idea should we do
that
where should we land where should we oh
my lands this bishop so
so there's really two candidates there's
bishop d7 but there's also bishop b7
we're gonna go bishop b7 and a lot of
people i know are wait a second aren't
you
isn't the bishop staring at the pawn
well it is but what i'm thinking is that
later on i'm gonna go d4
i'm gonna open up the bishop right and
that bishop is gonna be breathing
we can't do that immediately because the
bishop's gonna hang so let's reposition
the bishop on
a defended square so that we could go d4
is a trade good for us here it certainly
is we're up two puns we don't mind a
trade of bishops
uh we certainly don't mind an end game
there is one thing that i want to get
done here
you see that his rook is on the b file i
don't like the fact that he's got
control of the b
file how can we prevent him from
bringing that under full control what
should we kind of
do uh before we do anything else
and there's two things that need to be
done in a position like this the first
is to go rook ba
what is the second sort of russian
school of chess
take care of your future self kind of
move and first we're gonna go t4 and
take the bishop
but in general in such positions it's a
good idea to do what just to make sure
that nothing goes
terribly wrong in the future we take the
opportunity to make some luft
very good and we are going to make some
luff by playing g6
why am i not playing h6 because the
queen is guarding that's h7 square
and now we're going to continue to
expand in the center so for that reason
i think g7 is a more
uh you know is a more sensible square to
open up and now what should we do
what should we do in this position how
do we respond to the tension
that he has created a very very natural
move we should
definitely push and create two connected
passers and let's push it even further
and now we open up a queen
so dark salvation 87 thanks for
subbing with the prime again
i know that i'm not explaining
everything at the granular level that i
was
earlier but play has gotten tighter and
i warned you about this
uh for that reason i will be a little
bit deeper after the game what should we
do
fork d3 that's why we put our queen on
d6 he's lost
he's busted he's got to lose one of
these two pieces
and the game is over okay we have a very
cute move here
a lot of people would reject d take c2
because our queen is hanging but let's
look a little bit deeper than that we
can actually still take
for the reason that uh we will be able
to promote with check
and i'm trying to find a more beautiful
win there but no this is good enough
we're gonna promote with check and we're
gonna be up a rook now let's just get
the queen to d2
threatening the ladder checkmate okay
one check and it's gonna be made on the
next move because uh
yeah very good okay so uh
one more game and let's now switch to
two games at a time because the games
have gotten a little bit more complex
there's a lot to talk about
and i have a lot of stuff to lay out for
you guys so so that the next set of
games are going to be a little bit more
understandable
so let's play one more game and then
we're going to talk about them
okay uh slash nine and let's go e4
no i'm playing random people in the pool
and here we see a sicilian i think for
the very first time
and uh i'm gonna play the open sicilian
which
is good night butter thank you so much
for the for the support and and
just just an honor so have a great night
okay so he already has made a mistake
the move d6
is not how you play the sicilian you
want to take d4 instead
why is d6 a mistake why does this allow
what does this allow us to do
um it's it's a weird move it allows us
to expand in the center and kick his
knight away
and now he is nowhere good to put the
knight if he puts his puts it on e5 he
ruins his pawn structure very early
if he well and he does and we're going
to take it now
a lot of people would play knight c3 i
think that's a positional mistake
when the position is transformed in a
way like this we want to ask ourselves
we want to develop more purposefully and
this pawn on e5 is weak
how can we use this knight in order to
attack the pawn where should we put it
a lot of people want to play the move c4
but i actually think that's not the best
thing we can do let's reserve that
square for what
let's reserve that square for the knight
either knight t2 f3 or knight t2 c4
i would prefer to put the knight on c4
because if we put the knight on f3
he could pin us with a bishop on the
other hand
that would leave open the possibility of
giving a check
but all of that is a moot point because
right now he is attacking the e41
how should we continue how should we
continue in order to reinforce the idea
of
of bringing the knight to c4 or f3 this
is what i mean with
purposeful development we're at a level
now where we can't just develop our
pieces to the same squares every game
let's support the pawn with c4
which basically means that yes we're
gonna have to put the knight to f3
our development has to react more
dynamically to the to the necessities of
the position thank you
to you thank you nemo uh for the
birthday wishes and we will do something
very soon
uh and uh just an honor to have done so
many call-ups with you thank you nemo
for the six months okay so he's castled
what do we do
what do we do we can grab the pawn
yeah let's grab the pawn i would
personally have castled first and i will
explain why after the game
i will explain why after the game this
is a little bit iffy because okay knight
d7 is not the best
thing to do now we have a choice between
trading
or dropping the knight back let's
actually drop the knight back and the
reason why
is because in addition to a space sorry
in addition to being an extra pawn
to having an extra pawn we have a space
advantage and when you have a space
advantage
you generally want to keep more pieces
on the board there's no reason to
lighten the load for him by trading the
knights this knight on f3 is very nice
because it's it's pressuring e5 and it's
tying down his knight to e5
by tying down his knight we're also not
allowing him to develop his bishop he's
made a good move here
to untie his knight but there's many
ways to play here there's many possible
plans
uh one plan is to start expanding on the
queen side
and how should we first let's play h3
before we do anything else
let's play h3 to stop ideas of bishop g4
the way that you would expand on the
queen side is by preparing the b4 pawn
push
how should we prepare that pawn push
what should we do
in order to prepare the b4 pawn push
let's go a3
we're at a level guys where the plans
that we execute are no longer
one move plans okay they take two or
three moves and
that's okay that's just part of getting
better at chess okay so he
wants to sack on h3 which is actually
not a dangerous idea but i want to show
you guys the power of prophylax well
actually no this is such an empty idea
that we don't even really have to do
anything about it
okay let's go now rook c1 to x-ray his
queen
we've gone before we've introduced an
another source of pressure and he has
sacrificed his bishop
a lot of people would be scared by this
sacrifice why am i not scared
and what do we want to do about this
well actually this is not a bad idea
but in order to defend against it we
have to create an escape
route for our king and we have to
realize that he really doesn't have any
threats other than to give us a check on
g4
the way that we will deal remember if we
move the knight away
then we would give up this bishop so
let's go rookie one for two reasons
the first is that we open up an escape
route for the king to the center
king is usually safer in the center in
these kinds of positions because the
center is closed the second thing we're
preparing to do
is bishop f1 bishop g2 knight chief iv
does not prepare for mate that's what
people would think and that's what
scares people
but he's not actually threatening
checkmate this knight on f3 is guarding
h2
at this level the margins of victory are
much narrower that's just the reality
and i mentioned this yesterday you can't
be afraid of phantom threats you have to
determine
whether or not he's actually threatening
anything if the answer is no then the
answer is no
again this guy is playing extremely well
for his level extremely well
and i would be very impressed if he
would play a five here which he does
now we're going to bring the rook into
the game to reinforce the knight
and and we just have a lot of beef here
on the king's side he doesn't have
enough pieces
with which to truly attack again i am
very impressed with how he's able to
play this now
what should we do in order to bring this
rook over to h3 what do we have to do
what do we have to do we have to
move the knight away the reason most
people would not move the knight is
because they would be scared of the
check on h2 but guess what
why would we why did we move the rook to
e1 we move the rook d1 precisely
to take the sting out of the check on h2
we simply slide the king and now we get
the rook to h3 get out of here
not only does the queen have to move
away from h5 but in addition to that his
position just begins to collapse because
once the queen moves away
he exposes the h7 pawn we can take that
pawn and then we can come back to g5 we
have our own h file that's open now i
don't care about winning a pawn here i
care about opening that h file
so that we can actually start to attack
ourselves let's get the knight back
and now the time has come to open up the
board his position is sufficiently
weakened
to where we can afford to open up the f
file uh and and our pieces stream in
and just deliver checkmate in many
different ways yeah
this is um this guy is very good but he
started to collapse
what do we do rook takes f5 how do we
continue
we take tonight
we simply take the night now we're up
two pieces his attack is evaporated
and as often happens phil jackson
legendary coach of the la lakers
he made this point in basketball that if
you shoot a three-pointer from the
corner
and it's missed it often results in a
dunk at the other end of
the board at the other end of the court
uh and i won't go into the details of
that it's actually a fantastic point and
i'm a big basketball fan so i find that
to be a very instructive point
but it's a similar thing in chess right
when you do one of these attacks and it
backfires
an attack by the opponent often results
in an attack by the opposing side when
it fails
because of the sacrifices literally and
figuratively that you make
uh when and of course of the bulls of
the sacrifices that you make when you're
attacking you open up your own king
you do all this stuff like player 5 when
the attack backfires
one of the silver linings at the end of
the road is that
you can turn that attack around and
attack your opponents
thanks again for the incredible support
today we're going to go back to e5 here
and try to
work a little bit more on mastering
these basics now he goes for their eye
lopez we have faced this exactly once
and we go a6 people probably already
know
that bishop takes c6 leads to the
exchange variation
he's playing the main line of the red
lopez white is usually supposed to
castle he goes d3 which is a very
solid and very sensible sideline now
we're going to go b5
to get rid of the tension on that knight
here we can either develop our bishop to
e7 which is the more solid move
but we're going to develop it to c5 that
is the more ambitious line
but you guys know me i like the
ambitious options and we're going to
cement that bishop by playing d6
okay so he's actually playing this well
nothing
crazy and i mentioned earlier the
similarity between the rai lopez and the
italian
well here you see it right this is a
very similar position to what happens in
the italian
now do we take the pawn here do we take
on d4 or do we drop our bishop directly
what do you guys think
okay people are saying take i'm not sure
why
why can somebody explain the case for
taking
what is the case for taking on d4 no we
don't we actually don't take
uh and and the short reason and i will
explain this after the game
short reason behind not taking uh is is
what our opponent did a couple games ago
right you yields
better control of the center for white
that e4 pawn is operating uncontested if
we take on d4
part of the reason e4e5 has withstood
the test of time is because
fundamentally if you think about it in a
very granular level
you are occupying the same amount of
center that white is and and giving away
that center is something that needs to
be done very very carefully in addition
you open
an avenue down the c file and i'll talk
about that later so i talked about one
of white's main ideas
in the italian black has exactly the
same idea
what am i talking about what should we
do next
what should we do next and the is
thinking in the right direction we
should definitely think about starting
an attack on the king's side
but the reality is the center being
closed is a blessing in disguise
and the reason why is if you look at
this bishop it's just staring at
the pawn if we go c6 we do him a solid
by opening up the bishop
and it will once again begin operating
at its full potential the move d5 that
he has made is actually very premature
because it's opened up our bishop and
it's closed off his
this knight can go to f4 but let's not
go there immediately let's be patient
in order to attack on the king side we
do need to open something up
but what exactly is it and how are we
going to open up that king side to get
more of our pieces involved
let's think about it that way maybe
somebody can just name the idea we want
to push the f
on two squares in order to push the f on
two squares we want to do it very
carefully
the move knight h5 is the typical way of
repairing f5 there's a small tactic with
knight takes c5 okay so
he's gone h3 which is usually a very bad
move in these positions because he's
actually weakening
his position even more and the reality
is uh we don't even need to play f5 i
think we can get away with not doing it
at all
uh because of the move h3 he's created a
hook on which we can as we already know
sacrifice our bishop
and the reason i put this knight on f4
and not the others because now
we can still play f5 at our leisure when
the time
and the conditions are right but maybe
we can just get away with not doing it
at all
in fact we're sort of eyeing the
sacrifice on h3 as a potential way to
rip apart his king side
we'll see what he does uh this depends
entirely on how he chooses to defend but
the move h3 and this is something you
can apply
in terms of defending you want to be
super careful about these kinds of moves
that
voluntarily make weaknesses near the
king
let's go let's take it but then the
follow-up move is going to be a very
important one
once he takes on h3 we don't actually
want to take back with the knight we
want to include more beef in the attack
what does that mean what move should we
play after
he takes on h3 yes queen d7 is correct
we want to recapture with the queen
and that is a crucial cog in the machine
here if we just take on h3 greedily
we might end up with not enough pieces
in the attack we've
already seen this idea before very
similarly at least uh in
in one of our white games that's the
magic of chess you can borrow ideas
across openings across colors uh and
across uh opponents and tournaments and
all of that stuff that's why it's so
important to analyze your own games
partially
because not only do you figure out your
weaknesses but in addition to that
you also uh you know you get so much
better at
understanding uh ideas and your your
database of
understanding grows wider and wider now
he's made a very good move here
and actually was hoping he would make it
because this shows us why we got to be
very careful
about sacrifices like these and why
sometimes that is unnecessary
he has found the correct defense
bringing his queen in
i anticipated this trust me on this and
this is the moment when a lot of people
would panic and they would say damn you
know the attack didn't work
we're lost we didn't check made him on
g2
guess what we have two puns for the
piece
we still have a beautiful knight we
still have the possibility of
organizing an attack and i want to make
it very clear that when something fails
in chess when you find
like you want to attack you feel like
you're on the cusp of delivering mate
and then something happens it goes wrong
and your our opponent finds a defense
you want to be very calm and you want to
be very realistic
about understanding exactly how bad the
situation is and the situation here is
not that bad
we still have some pawns for the piece
and we still have a huge attack we just
got to bring more pieces in that's all
we have to do
and now we're going to play a five to
sacrifice upon and we're just gonna try
to open some more stuff up here some
more files
some more avenues for our pieces uh he
goes 92
okay so he's actually once again playing
very very very well
and surprisingly but he's allowing me
now to open up that f-file
uh and now that pawn on f2 is gonna get
caught in the crossfire and
predictably he makes a big blunder he
doesn't realize the significance
of that pawn of that file being open we
see first of all the x-ray between the
rook and the queen which immediately
leads us to the question
can we move our knight away and win the
queen we can knight h3
is this square defended it absolutely is
by our queen
that we slid to h6 how did i find this
move
well i remember yes or sarah wants
comment right the queen is often best in
a supporting actress role
it can be just as effective from behind
as it can be from the front
we have one a queen we still keep all of
our attack going strong and
the game should end very very soon okay
so he now blunders f2 and the position
collapses
okay boom boom and he's just going to
lose all of his pieces so we can play
this relatively fast
a very good defensive job by our
opponent here who found that idea of
bringing the queen
uh into the defense so kudos
kudos to my opponent for for awesome
plane
okay and he resigns let's analyze and
then we'll wrap up for today
okay so uh just to recap a couple of key
moments early in the game
the reason that we don't take is that we
give him amazing control of the center
and how is that control manifested
well he's threatening e5 and that move
will exploit the pin that he has just
orchestrated remember that in such
positions
the move g5 is going to be very
dangerous by definition because
of the possibility of that sacrifice so
so this lands us in completely
unnecessary trouble particularly since
we can simply drop the bishop back
and if we count the defenders and the
attackers we've got two defenders on e5
two attackers which means this is
perfectly safe
and yes you can trade queens and at this
higher level
you have to open yourself up to the
possibility that you will have end games
uh and that's not something that you can
entirely avoid in all variations that's
a foolish way to be
the move d5 is very tempting but it's a
mistake thank you cami this is a mistake
because he blocks his own bishop as i
talked about and he actually helps us
improve our own knights
my knight wants to be on g6 and he's
basically helping us get there
anyway uh and here we go knight h5 to
prepare f5
and to get our knight to f4 now if i
were playing black
okay and and this was a classical game i
would not sack on h3
what instead would i do what would black
do and you already know that this is the
idea
but this would be probably the best move
the black has
f5 definitely f5 to open more stuff up
but
let's say that you wanted to prepare
bishop takes h3 can somebody find a very
sneaky three move idea
that actually prepares bishop takes h3
and it would be a little bit of a
stubborn idea i don't love it but just
to give you guys some practice
thinking about plans and maneuvers how
would you prepare yep very nice potato
for president bishop d7 queen c8
building a little battery
and then we could take on h3 the problem
with that idea is that it's a little bit
too slow
and it gives white a chance to bring in
some defenders one thing he could do
is he could drop his knight back to g1
and beef up the security on that pawn
but we could play f5 here now that we've
sort of
compromised white's defensive position
but that would all be too complicated i
would just play a 5. so our opponents
actually did find and we got a donation
oh we got another hundred bucks from vp
bombazi
uh another incredibly generous supporter
of my stream for so long thank you vp
you're the best
and another 100 bucks dropped on me this
is unbelievable
support today it's raining raining from
the sky
and uh uh this is awesome
this is this is awesome thank you vp so
much for your long-term support this is
not the only hundred dollar donation
he's made
uh so thank you so much appreciate him
hi man
okay um so how yeah
very well-deserved vip now if we did
play f5 uh we got a question about how
we would continue this attack well there
would be several ways to do that
and this would depend almost entirely
this would depend almost entirely on on
what white does thank you ultier for the
tier one
man this never ends uh one way would be
to pile up on that file perhaps build an
alekhine's gun
uh knight takes g2 would be on the cards
at some point
in order to isolate that knight on f3 if
he moves his knight away then we bring
our queen to the square that has now
been
freed up by the knight i want to
emphasize that there is no single
monolithic way to attack
okay thank you for the converting sub
pinky cliffy diffie
we've got the fireworks going strong
again
um and here we go now there is no one
way to attack our attack
must depend on three primary things okay
uh and and if people are interested in
truly improving
you can write this stuff down i think it
helped me i owed this to
some of my coaches who helped me
understand this thank you women's gm
adriana
an honor to have you in my stream as
well thank you for the sub
one of them is pieces an attack has to
have pieces involved
okay it's very hard to attack with a
single piece
the second thing is weaknesses
eventually you're gonna have to create
weaknesses near your opponent's king
that have to be used in a strategic way
uh
either weaknesses that you can checkmate
on or weak pieces or weak pawns
right and the third thing and this is
what people forget about
is reaction right you want to react
properly to your opponent's defensive
moves
and when you're attacking you want to
ask yourself what is the drawback of my
opponent's move what squares does it now
leave open where which i could use for
my pieces
a great example of this would be if he
moves his knight back from e1
maybe it's no longer as effective to get
to the file but now we have the g
file so so these three things when
properly combined
can give you a lot of attacking ability
anyways i don't want to belabor the
point here thank you rad broga for the
hundred bits
uh we had several questions what about
e4 e4 would be a great idea get that
knight out of there and then go queen
shoot for perfect
absolutely uh i would be a little bit
hesitant about e4 because
it would leave this night undefended by
a pawn and i like my pieces to be
defended by puns
but but that would be certainly
something to consider um
now our opponents actually found a very
nice defensive idea queen f3
and instead of panicking we just drop
our queen back and we're saying okay
this knight is still very strong now
we're going f5 to open more pieces up
open more files up what would have
happened if he takes on e5
how would we continue attacking here
well there's several ways to do it we
could bring our rook to e8 and prepare
e4
and open even more files up and try to
overextend some of his pieces
and one other very important thing and
this is truly high level stuff
right this is for the higher rated
people but everybody is welcome to
take a crack at it you're attacking one
of the things that people forget most
often
is that they get and this is a way of
sort of showing tunnel vision this is
this is a form of tunnel vision
when people attack they get too fixated
on checkmate they forget that one of the
byproducts of a weak king is that you
can use that weak king as a springboard
to to also win material winning material
is a very natural conclusion to a lot of
attacks it's not only about checkmate
the weak king
is not a liability only because it can
get checkmated but also because you can
use it to deliver checks
as a way of actively transferring your
pieces to squares where they can deliver
forks
and pins and skewers and that is exactly
what plaque can do here
to win back the piece let's find
the sequence let's find the sequence
knight h3 and knight g5 bingo and
everybody sees it this is awesome
awesome to see
pin oh sorry fork attacking the queen
attacking the bishop and the game is
over
uh because once we take the bishop
material equality has been responded
guess what
our rook is going to lift itself over to
h4 just wanted to share that piece of
advice we're going to
expand upon this in in great detail once
we get
you know a little bit up there but but
the concept of winning material when
you're attacking is oftentimes
uh missed by a lot of people again this
might seem a little bit
you know vague but i promise that we
will build on this advice
as we go along okay so he went 92 we
opened up the file he should have taken
with the queen here what would we have
done
had he taken with the queen thank you
and let's not forget whose idea this
whole speed run was what would have
happened had he taken on e3
no this is not 2 000 plus stuff it's
stuff that is
applicable by anybody but how should i
put this i would say that there is
bigger fish to fry when you're 1200 than
to try to like actively apply this
advice
uh but but but that doesn't mean you
can't do it and and
i wanted to yeah absolutely robert
i'm gonna keep a close eye on your
answer though
yeah i don't think hess can get this
he's he's i
i don't think he's known for his tactics
i don't know why anybody would
commentate with someone like that really
do you guys have any idea who would ever
commentate with someone like that
queen g oh yes chuck mccheck and
checkmate amazing job bye grandmaster
has
yeah so knight h3 and the knight takes
f2 and now his king is entirely exposed
and queen h3 is
is gonna be crushing so this would have
been the results of taking with the
queen but here of course we win the
queen
um here of course we win the queen
so oh right queen takes c4 and 92
oh he was oh actually we're serious
so knight takes e2 and you go into the
end game
see i couldn't tell actually this is a
very nice idea queen g6 check
man this guy actually knows what he's
talking about who is this guy i've never
seen him before
um this uh this is quite the surprise
uh hes seeing some tactics come on come
on man
yeah this is very nice so here we win
back the piece and we go into an end
game up i think three puns
uh now knight h3 knight f2 is also of
course crushing because of this but
white can get into the end game
uh also down a bunch of pawns so this
would be
also very nice very nice idea queen 26
thank you so
sillam rm for the tier one he's almost
playing like a gm
but he took with the bishop and made our
job very easy goodnight h3 just uh
winning the queen
and uh the rest was very easy and that's
what often happens you lose one piece
and and everything collapses
the move c takes d4 is is the main move
and this leads to the openstacilian
black has
black has many variations here yesterday
i played the accelerated dragon there's
also the sveshnikov
or black play z5 there's the rouser and
all of these are full-fledged position
full-fledged sicilian lines they all
have their own pluses and minuses
thank you son of zoo for the twitch
prime um and let me re-enable the alert
box
uh now he played d6 which delays the
capture
and allows us uh the possibility to play
d5 and
kick the knight away he goes 95 we take
the knight and this is where
i introduce the concept of purposeful
developments
the structures that you get at a higher
level are going to be a little bit more
unusual you're not going to get the same
openings every time because people play
different stuff
and you've got to be able to dynamically
adjust your play and your development
particularly
particularly your development to exactly
what it is your opponent is doing don't
just generically play knight c3 because
that's where you usually put the knight
try to approach the situation concretely
and logically
okay the pawn on e5 is weak it's doubled
it's hard to defend
how what is a good piece that acts kind
of like a screwdriver that acts like a
chisel
okay it's the knight where can we put
the knight to
attack the pawn we can put it on c4 f3
but daniel doesn't
doesn't this take two moves okay didn't
you say you should only develop each
piece once
right that's the basic principle but the
higher level you get as i've said
the more principles that you violate
strategically
because he himself has not developed any
pieces we can actually afford
to burn another tempo and put the knight
on a better square
okay so bishop d3 now we go c4 we don't
want to give up this pawn this pawn
is the reason why we're better right
it's a bone in his throat we go c4 and
we eliminate that square from the knight
but remember we still have the f3 square
knight f3 knight takes c5 we just snag
upon
go back to f3 we don't want to trade
knights for no reason
okay so here we go h3 we prepared before
everything here is very simple
and this is the moment i wanted to focus
on um
oh jeremy why would i castle instead of
snagging the pawn so basically if we
snagged the pawn
i was a little bit concerned that he
would start
bothering me down the e-file and i
thought that if we castle
uh maybe that's just a little bit safer
we don't really actually need this pawn
for our advantage
but now that i look at it i think taking
the pawn was a good idea i i don't agree
with
with what i said earlier i don't think
that would have been dangerous
uh so i prepared before here which is a
very typical plan in such positions i'm
trying to set my pawn
advantage in motion and for that to
happen i'm going to have to get rid of
one of his pawns
getting rid of his other pawn is going
to be very hard because it's easy to
defend with the rook
and so for that reason i'm trying to get
rid of this one
okay let's say that you saw this move
and you said all right you know what
i know that this attack isn't dangerous
but i'm going to defend against it
anyway
how would we go about preventing bishop
takes h3
if we happen to be afraid of it if we
have if he happened to be afraid of it
we would go king h2 all right and the
king would lend support to this pawn if
he takes
we simply take back and he simply has no
follow-up the move g4
i would caution you against that is a
knee-jerk response be careful so that
the medicine isn't worse than the
disease
here he can take on g4 and the attack is
actually
much stronger than it would have been if
he takes on h3 right he gets a tempo
with chuck
uh the reason that i didn't play king h2
and this is a very advanced thing so i
know that
there are higher rated among you and um
you know i i i haven't forgotten about
you guys
why did i not play king h2 uh there is a
specific reason and then there is a
conceptual
reason there is something i didn't like
about the placement of this king
which is why i didn't do this i almost
did
can somebody name either of these
reasons specific and conceptual
yes so the bishop on d6 is
is x-raying the king i hate putting my
king in one of these situations when it
gets
x-rayed uh and you might look at this
and say well i don't care about the
x-ray he's got a pawn on e5 what does it
matter
uh this is completely blocking in the
bishop and so is this
well that's where tactics come in
tactics are a way of making stuff happen
that might seem impossible
and can somebody find a tactic to try to
open this bishop up
what what can black try to do uh to get
this pawn moving and deliver that
discover check you can sack on e4
remove the pawn now he can remove the
bishop
and guess what he goes e4 now yes this
is not a disaster for white you can just
move the king and at the end of the day
you're still a pawn
but i'm not trying to be that specific
i'm just trying to show you guys
some of the conceptual reasons that go
behind my intuition that's why i was a
little bit reticent about king h2
another thing i could have done here is
gone rookie one this is a very
high level deep move rookie one is a
great example of
indirect prophylaxis direct prophylaxis
would be king h2
this means literally stopping your
opponent's threat indirect prophylaxis
is a way of allowing your opponent to do
what he wants to do but taking the sting
out of it entirely
how do we take the sting out of bishop
takes h3 with the mover q1
well i actually played this move in the
game so
you guys know what the idea is what
would i do now to
fully throw water onto the fire and
extinguish the attack entirely now we
would go bishop f1
so this move in and of itself is a
little bit awkward right the rook gets
onto a closed file
but the point is not to improve the
rook's position the point is to involve
the bishop in the defense
and if he doesn't take on h3 we can shut
down this idea permanently
by playing bishop f1 i think that this
would have actually been even better
than what i did right i played rook c1
here
to get the rook onto a file where it
x-rays the queen
but i i should have probably gone rookie
one just to operate with a higher margin
of safety
now this is important because h2 is
covered some people were very afraid of
this
but if you look specifically at the
squares then you can see that that there
really isn't any uh
threats here and an attack is is a
function of the weakness of the king and
the number of pieces that participate in
that attack
uh and and if not that many pieces are
participating in the attack
then there's no magic here it's going to
be very hard to make stuff happen
particularly because we've involved
one two three defenders in the attack
uh and here comes a fourth defender and
at this point we locked the attack down
completely
by the way just to mention after sorry
for the
jumping around uh if we if he played
queen h2 check after knight g5 then we
just drop our king away and this is why
the bishop is so good
because it guards h1 and it guards all
of these squares
and it also supports rook h3 which by
the way would have trapped the queen
so you know attack is a very
double-sided thing it's not that your
opponent is only having all the fun
all right that was uh that was a
mouthful but hopefully this makes
uh some sense to people how do i see
this
well i can recommend to some of the
higher rateds among you there is a very
good chess book called secrets of chess
defense
by one of my favorite uh romanian
grandmasters miguel maher and he's an
amazing instructor
i wrote his name in the chat he wrote
several amazing books i can
highly recommend secrets of chess
defense i can also recommend
looking at the games of tigrand
petrossian particularly the book python
strategy
petrosian and i've talked about that
before has this reputation as
as a boring player very positional makes
a lot of draws
but guess what if you if you want to get
better at chess
you have to master the skills that are
not as glamorous as attacking and
sacrificing and one of those skills
is prophylaxis and defending on a larger
scale
and one of the best ways of learning how
to do stuff is to watch people who do it
a lot better than you do and i
apply that constantly and it's
responsible for a lot of my growth and
improvement as a player and i think as a
coach as well
there's a lot of coaches i think who are
more experienced than me and better than
me
uh and uh i look up to them one of them
is miguel marin
and you can learn from them and the same
goes for specific chess improvement
uh and and these books are i would say a
little bit higher level
if you're a beginner i would say that
you should focus more
on tactics calculation recognizing basic
patterns and once you get 1300 or so
then you can consider incorporating
other types of training such as
prophylaxis and defense
uh okay and i wouldn't say under 2000
it's not necessary
if you're talking about the book do you
have to trust your opponent hasn't
calculated an attack
yeah you should never trust your
opponent you should always assume
uh that your opponent might have
blundered something that that doesn't
mean you shouldn't disrespect your
opponent you should assume that your
opponent has something up his sleeve
but at the same time you shouldn't take
your opponent's word on anything
and that includes sacrifices and attacks
and all that jazz
uh because people are capable of not
only bluffing but honest mistakes your
opponent may have thought
that that the attack works but he might
have just missed
uh he might have just missed uh you know
some sort of specifics within the attack
some sort of option there
and you should always open your mind up
to that okay
um let us analyze recognizing your
opponent's resources by veretsky i have
that book
i wouldn't recommend it to anybody under
2100
honestly i think there are better
resources for people in like the 16 1700
range
now let's get to the first game that i
played in this
series in which he played bishop c4 this
was a pretty one-sided game uh because
he blundered upon
by playing e5 and once i took this pawn
and the other pawn
the one important point that i wanted to
make is that these situations
have to cause you know
you have to be cautious in them right
because he's got the possibility for a
discovery if the king was on e7
he would have been able to win the queen
whenever a discovery is
in the air you should make sure that you
know there's no
sudden night move that that causes a lot
of trouble and looking at this
i actually see that i did indeed miss
the move knight b5
uh this move would have threatened
knight c7 and attacked my queen
and there's no way to move the queen
away and also defend against knight c7
so believe it or not this actually would
have been very strong
now i don't think black is worse here i
could have sacked the queen
and i have a lot of stuff for the queen
i have a rook and a piece and two pawns
but the reality is uh white's probably
the one calling the shots here so for
that reason
if i were playing a classical game i
would have just gotten my queen back
that is the first order of priority you
guys already know
from many of our discussions that the
queen is one of the biggest liabilities
in the opening when the queen is out
here alone
with no support from any of its pieces
uh it it can turn into a huge liability
because of the necessity to respond to
all the threats
and so oftentimes evacuating the queen
becomes the first priority
and that's that's what should have been
done queen b6
uh okay so after he missed
this opportunity i think things
stabilized in quite a
big way and this is a good example of a
situation in which
he's got no good discovery if he goes
knight d5 i just take the knight with
the queen
he moved his knight away and moved the
queen away and the rest is very
straightforward just occupying the
center
developing the bishop to its best square
and doing so with an eye toward the
future we're not just
willy-nilly putting it on any square
we're putting it on a square
so that once we open the diagonal the
bishop is going to be doing the most
that it can
okay and the rest was very
straightforward we take the b file away
from him
we make some luft we make some air for
our king and and the word luft by the
way means i think literally air in
german uh and that's how we refer
to moves like g6 which create a little
bit of a hole for the king
in order to avoid future back rank
checkmates
[Music]